ندوب الحرب شبكة روسيا المترامية الأطراف من
الدفاعات المحصنة، بما في ذلك أسنان
التنين سيئة السمعة، وهي تتشبث
بالأرض الأوكرانية، هذه الصور التي
التقطتها أجهزة الأمن الأوكرانية
وشاركتها حصريًا مع شبكة سي إن إن هي تذكير
بكل ما يكمن أمام القوات المتقدمة في كييف، حيث
حققت الهجمات المضادة
ببطء شديد حتى الآن، ولكن  بثبات، نحن لا نفشل، نحن
نمضي قدمًا، لقد حررنا
آلاف الكيلومترات المربعة من
أراضينا من خلال حقول الألغام بدون تغطية جوية
ونتطلع إلى الطبقة التالية من الدفاعات الروسية
مع طمأنة وزير خارجية البلاد
لحلفائنا الذين نفد صبرهم
وشركائنا الذين يساعدوننا
بما في ذلك  إنهم يفهمون الولايات المتحدة
أن الأمور تسير في
الاتجاه الصحيح ويدركون أنه
لا توجد مأساة أو أي نوع من
التباطؤ،
وفي الوقت نفسه تجدد روسيا المخاوف النووية، حيث
أعلنت وكالة الفضاء الروسية
أنها وضعت
صاروخ سارمات الباليستي العابر للقارات في حالة تأهب قتالي
مع شن هجمات على  تزيد الأراضي الروسية من
ضربات الطائرات بدون طيار التي كانت صادمة الآن، حيث
أعلن عمدة موسكو يوم الجمعة عن
إحباط هجوم آخر
بطائرات بدون طيار أوكرانية على العاصمة
وكذلك المناطق المحيطة بها،
كما أشاد المتحدث باسم وزارة الدفاع الروسية بالدفاعات الجوية الروسية، حيث
تم تدمير 281 مركبة جوية أوكرانية بدون طيار، بما في ذلك 1-  2-141 طائرة نفاثة
للشوارع بالإضافة إلى 29 طائرة بدون
طيار من نوع الطائرات الأوكرانية في المناطق الغربية من
الاتحاد الروسي
ولكن بعض الطائرات بدون طيار تمكنت من المرور هذا
الأسبوع. تظهر صور الأقمار الصناعية الجديدة هذه
الطائرات المتضررة في القاعدة الجوية كريستي في
منطقة بيسكوف الغربية في روسيا، حيث تم
شن هجوم  من داخل روسيا بحسب
كييف
بقايا الطائرات المحترقة هي
ندوب روسيا الخاصة بالحرب